- Before we shit on the
American Government,
and back alley politics, and all that,
why don't we talk about accountability.
Give me seven hot takes
on shit they can do.
Everybody, really excited
about this conversation with,
especially if you're listening,
we're recording/filming this prior
but you are listening to this podcast
as this book is coming out,
"Food Fix" is out today.
Please go to your local
bookstores or Amazon.com
or however you roll.
And the gentleman who wrote
it is with us here today.
So, Mark, why don't you
tell the VaynerNation,
who you are and what you do
and then why you wrote this
book and then we're gonna jam.
- You mean like, who I
am, the meaning of life,
my existential nature.
- Yes, yes.
(Mark laughing)
First, let's tell everybody your name.
- Okay. (chuckles)
I'm Dr. Mark Hyman, I'm a Physician,
I trained in Family Medicine
but have been practicing
functional medicine
for 25 years, which is
the science of health,
and how to find the root causes
of what's wrong with people
and get people better
by dealing with those.
- Instead of throwing medicine at it?
- It's not.
It's actually the science of health
is how do you create health?
The traditional medicine is focused on
diagnosing disease and treating it
with a drug usually or surgery.
It's a pill for every ill.
- Yeah.
- Functional medicine is about the science
of creating health by understanding
the imbalances in the system.
What are the toxins, algins,
microbes, stress, poor diet,
that's driving imbalances
and one of the things you
need that you don't get,
the right food nutrients,
balance of light, air, water,
connection, love, meaning,
all that is really how we create health
and it's phenomenal for chronic disease.
And I'm also the head of
Strategy and Innovation
for the Cleveland Clinic
Center for Functional Medicine,
I've written 12 New
York Times bestsellers,
I'm the host of The
Doctor's Farmacy podcast,
which is a top 200 podcast,
and I'm really on a mission to help get
to the end of needless suffering
through addressing chronic disease,
through functional medicine,
and fixing the food system.
Because I've been sitting
in my office for 30 years,
seeing patient after patient,
who's sick with chronic disease
that's caused mostly by food
and it's like being in a boat
that's sinking, with a bucket,
trying to bail it and I finally asked,
why are we seeing so
many people who are sick?
It's food.
And why do we have the food we have?
It's the food system.
And why do we have the food system?
It's our food policies.
And why do we have our food policies?
It's the food industry's
influence on policy.
There's 187 lobbyists for
every member of Congress,
it's the number one lobby group, by far,
which is the Food and Ag industry.
So that's really how I've
come to what I'm doing now,
which is really focusing on food,
it's medicine and food
as the solution to so
many of our global crises.
- You know it's funny,
because I'm sitting with you,
I'm gonna paint a picture for
everybody who's listening.
I'm sitting with you
and over your shoulder
is a wonderful team member of mine, Sunan,
who's worked with us for a while.
Who's, he's doing his best to not
have his head fully fall off his body.
(woman laughing)
Because you're talking and it's been,
it's something that he's
talked to me about personally,
without knowing exactly, you know,
he's talked about his father
in Turkey, he's from Turkey,
he's a great kid, and obviously,
you're a big buyer of this.
And it's fun for me because
when I talk about business,
I talk about, don't fix
the sink, fix the well.
- Yes.
- And so, this is, you know,
much like I invested in Facebook
one second into seeing it,
when Sunan first came
to me, he was like, hey,
I want to like really help
you because I care about you,
and you're doing everything wrong
and I want you to do this kind of shit.
Like,
I'm fascinated by
the 187 lobbyists to one.
I'm fascinated by the old system of life.
- Yeah.
- Government's life.
- Media, Government, life.
How today with social media,
everyone's blaming social
media for our problems,
yet what social media is
doing is exposing our truths.
- [Mark] That's true.
- And you're sitting in--
- There's a dark and a light side.
- Yeah, the dark and light
side because it's a mirror.
- Yeah.
- And so it's really funny,
you were literally just going
through your setup here,
you know, I see Sunan in the corner,
I'm thinking about, you know,
we're in an election year,
my profile has risen so much
that I get an uncanny amount
of direct messages of like,
I think I'm really passionate about
insecurity and like happiness
and I literally just to,
this is really fun, it's
really exciting for me for you
because if I'm hearing
your narrative right,
the amount of buyers of
what you were putting down
25-30 years ago--
- Not too many.
- Right, in comparison to today.
- Yeah.
- But more importantly,
in comparison to today, the
infrastructure of communication
in an internet world--
- Yeah.
- Which is the real actual counter
to 187 to one.
- Yeah, it's huge.
- I'm just like literally
sitting here starting
to get goosebumps of like, oh okay,
this is really gonna be a big
fucking deal in 30 years--
- It is.
- Because we're in halftime
right now.
- Yeah.
- For you, this is in you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- In your paradigm.
- Yeah.
- The last, you know again, 30 years,
and that's why I said it and you laughed.
You have very few buyers.
You have a lot more buyers now.
And the non-buyers are curious,
or financially vested interest
to put their head in the sand or scared.
I'm a scared guy.
Like, for example, I'm a really funny guy.
(Mark laughing)
If I didn't have to go to the
doctor ever again in my life
in any shape or form,
that would be best for me.
And like, I'd rather give
up those 23 years of life,
than go to the doctor.
That's how much I hate it.
I'm being serious.
- Yeah.
- I being very transparent.
- But you can also be the
CEO of your own health and--
- Listen.
There's nothing you're
gonna say that isn't wrong
and I'm about to say
everything that's wrong.
Like I know that to be true
because it's the other
parallel of my life,
where I see it in reverse in other areas.
So nonetheless, with
all that setup from you
and then my little rant here
let me take it in a little
bit of a different direction
'cause you have me excited.
What's going on in this macro converse,
are you like as a human, how old are you?
- How old do you think I am?
- You are, you said, 25-30 years.
You're 53.
- 60.
- Beautiful.
(Mark laughing)
Where you are right now, are you pumped
because you're like, fuck,
something that like was so fucked
30 years ago--
- I am so excited.
- Is clearly on it's way?
- You know why?
I am so excited because the
food industry is so screwed up.
Right, it's causing six out
of 10 Americans to be sick.
It's bankrupting our country.
You know, one out of every two Medicare,
one out of every $2 in our
mandatory federal spending
in five years will be for Medicare,
which is mostly for chronic disease.
We're seeing climate change
being affected by food,
it's the number one
cause of climate change.
We're seeing poverty, social
injustice, mental illness,
academic challenges in kids, depression,
even national security issues
because kids are too
fat or unfit to fight.
These are all in part caused by food.
Food industry is the number
one cause of climate change.
So as I look at all
these separate problems,
I'm so excited because
if food was the cause,
it's also the cure.
- The cure, 100%.
- And we have the power
to change all that.
I see this all the time in my practice
where we take people who
have heart failure, diabetes,
early kidney failure, fatty
liver, all these problems,
and we can reverse it with food,
but we can't do that with the
current food system we have.
It has to change.
And--
- So, gimme.
- I can give you--
- Please.
- A really quick example
of why I'm so excited.
The last few days, Burger
King launched an ad
that showed a big Whopper
that went moldy over 34 days
and the punch line was, there's
no artificial preservatives.
Now, it's still a whopper,
it's still not healthy for you,
but the idea that--
- It's a better whopper
than what it was 10 years ago.
- That a fast food country,
fast food company would--
- No, you said it right the first time.
- A fast food country.
- Yeah, that's true. (laughs)
A fast food country
company would lead with,
we're cleaning up our food
because the consumers
are driving the behavior.
We're seeing Nestle's
doing different things.
We're seeing Kellogg's saying,
no more glyphosate in our cereal.
General Mills, we're
gonna move a million acres
into regenerative agriculture,
which will bring back the soil
and preserve the land
and actually help us
prevent climate change.
It's powerful when you
see these companies--
- This is a country of currency.
This is an entrepreneurial
capitalistic country
and the reason I asked you the question,
and I appreciate your answer,
and I was hoping it is
'cause you must be pumped.
It's similar to me, like in 25 years,
when entrepreneurs and business people
think being happy and kind is better
than having a boat and being a dickface,
I'll be happy.
(Mark laughing)
Honestly, I'm actually projecting here.
- And you know what
makes people dickfaces?
Often what they're eating.
- Yes.
- Because it inflames their brain,
literally the science is so
clear that mental illness,
even violence in prisons,
you give violent prisoners
healthy food in prisons,
the violent crime goes down by 56%
and you give 'em a vitamin
and it goes down by 80%.
- Let's make this fun
and let me take this in
a couple different places
because you're gonna do
plenty of other podcasts,
you have your own,
you're gonna be able to beat that drum.
I want to take this a little
bit of a different direction,
meaning, a framework that I
want to have this convo in.
Talk to me about this, rigid.
Give me five to seven bullets
that needs to happen at the micro,
before we go into the systematic change
that you're passionate about,
because I heard you, you know,
system, system, system--
- Yes.
- Honestly, I'm gonna ask
you this 'cause I'm curious.
- Yeah.
- That's more me.
For everybody who's listening,
'cause I'm fascinated by this,
give me seven to 12, hot takes,
bullets of questions or statements
that every single person
that's listening right now,
should think about on a personal level,
that they can achieve,
because humans when they
hear 187 lobbyists to one,
(Mark laughing)
immediately go into, fuck,
I can't change it anyway--
- Yeah.
- Fuck this.
- So let's talk about accountability.
- Absolutely.
- Before we shit on the
American government,
and back alley politics, and all that,
why don't we talk about accountability.
Give me seven hot takes
on shit they can do.
- Absolutely.
- Go.
- So, in "Food Fix", my
book, how to save our health,
our economy, our
communities, and our planet,
one bite at a time, it's called "Food Fix"
it's not called food apocalypse,
because it's focused on what
we can do and what you can do.
And yes, we need the political change
but on a personal level--
- Yes.
- You can focus your diet
to become more aspirational
towards being a regenitarian.
Now, what the heck is that?
- So let's talk about that.
- What is that?
- I like that.
That sounds like I can live--
- It's very cool.
That's a whole different framework.
So regenerative agriculture
is a way of growing food,
it grows higher quality food,
they build the soil with organic matter
that draws carbon out of the atmosphere.
Literally, most of the carbon,
a third of the carbon that's
in the atmosphere today
came from the destruction of our soil,
we can put it back in the soil.
Better than rain forest.
- That's interesting.
- So it'll help the soil,
it'll conserve water, we're losing,
water scarcity is a huge
thing around the world
and we're seeing floods and droughts,
that can be solved by fixing
the soil through these methods.
It actually can reduce the use
of pesticides, fertilizers,
and all these harmful things.
It's better for the animals
because they're grazing around,
it increases biodiversity,
our pollinators are dying,
75% are lost, bees and butterflies,
that can be rebuilt through
regenerative agriculture.
So if you seek out foods from farms
that are using these methods,
and you can do it at your
local farmer's market,
you can join a community
support of agriculture
in your community,
you can go online and
find regenerative meat,
for example, from places
like Mariposa Ranch,
where you can get a pound
of meat for an average
of eight bucks a pound, which per serving,
is probably about the same or less
than a McDonald's hamburger.
And you can start to look for sources
and you can't be perfect
and nobody's perfect,
I'm not perfect, but being aspirational--
- Where are you most imperfect currently?
What's your favorite
thing to be imperfect at?
This is powerful.
- I think I'm most imperfect
about how much I work.
I need to...
(chuckles)
But the reason I work so hard--
- What about what you put
in your body food wise?
Give me like a Twizzler,
give me something that--
- Never, never.
A Twizzler never happens.
- Okay, give me something.
But let's be vulnerable here.
- What does happen--
- [Gary] Cause this will
encourage them to be better.
- Is ice cream.
- Okay, good.
- I have a weak,
a couple times a year,
I'll dig into ice cream.
- Let me ask you a question,
when you eat ice cream,
are you like doing it at home because--
- No.
- You're like fuck,
if I'm outside and
somebody takes a photo--
- I have to tell you the funniest story.
So--
- Give it to me.
- So, I was at a medical
conference at Harvard and Tufts
and the Dean of the Tufts
School of Nutrition,
the former CEO of Whole Foods,
one of the leading, sort of,
scientists in Food as Medicine was there--
- Yeah, it's like a legit thing.
- And we were, the five
of us, we're like buddies,
and we're like, all right,
we're gonna sneak out from this conference
and we're gonna go get gelato.
And I'm sitting there on
the corner eating gelato
and this woman comes up,
she says, "Dr. Hyman!"
I'm like, oh shit, I'm busted.
(laughing)
I'm busted.
But you know--
- It's powerful to talk about that though.
I think most people break,
you know it's funny.
- I eat real food, where I don't eat,
I don't eat industrial food.
So in other words, if it's some product
that was made in a factory,
that's industrial food,
that's not real food, I
generally won't eat it.
But I will eat sweets
sometimes, I'll have, you know,
cake or I'll have a chocolate
or I'll have ice cream.
- So, you'll enough of a sweet tooth that
that's the battle, right?
- Yeah, but I...
The thing is when you
regulate your mileage,
you don't really want that stuff anymore.
You crave, like, vegetables
and it sounds crazy but yes,
you can crave vegetables.
- I love that. That's always
been an easy one for me.
- So those are some simple fixes
and then you can help end food waste.
Food waste is crazy.
We waste a pound of food for every person,
every day, in this country,
it's 40% of our food
and globally it's 40%.
It's the food that would need
to be grown on an landmass
the size of China, it's
over $2 trillion of waste,
and that's not the worst part--
- How does one do that?
So, if somebody--
- The worst, I'll tell ya,
the worst part is, we throw
our scraps and our food
the waste, into landfills.
We throw it into landfills
where it creates methane,
that's 25 times more potent
than greenhouse gas and carbon monoxide.
- So, what can Zac do?
- It's a huge contributor
to climate change.
- [Gary] So, what can Zac do?
- So, what Zac can do is--
- Looks nice and tan.
- If he lives in the city,
he can get a little in-apartment composter
where you throw your food scraps
and it turns it into this humus soil,
that you can give to your
local farmer's market,
I'm sure the farmers will take it.
- How do we get people to not hear,
that's annoying as shit?
- You know, we have actually,
I'm moving into a new apartment building
and there's a composting thing.
So in San Francisco it's mandatory.
You get a fine if you don't compost.
In France it's mandatory, you go to jail
or you get a fine if you don't compost.
In Massachusetts--
- Jail sounds good.
- Yeah, jail is good. (chuckles)
You know?
- No, honestly,
we need to get into like, jail.
- I don't know. (laughing)
- Like, no, I think about this.
I'll tell you why I'm jumping on that.
I'm thinking a lot about,
I think we need more dictate,
like I'm not kidding.
- Yes.
- We need more dictatorship.
I think a lot of what America,
at this maturity of an
empire is caught with,
why we're so extreme in left and right,
is like, there needs to
be thoughtful jailing.
- Yeah, well you know,
in America, the FDA--
- Like, for example, recycling,
we're supposed to recycle too.
- Yes.
- Many people do not.
- Yes, they don't.
- And because nothing works
when there's no ramifications.
Let me promise you something right now,
if everybody got a ticket,
like a DM, all of a sudden,
with like a bill, that you had
to pay like a parking ticket,
because it was easy to see
that you didn't recycle in your building.
I have a funny feeling
people would quickly.
- [Mark] Oh, sure.
- The reason nobody cares about privacy,
you know how my tech world,
like in this society now
we talk about privacy
is 'cause nobody's money is
getting taken away forever
so that's why you keep throwing
around your information.
There's no actual ramifications.
- Well, consequences.
- No consequences.
- There are, they're just
more invisible, right?
- Yes.
- Our free will is being usurped
by targeted digital strategies.
- [Gary] But is it?
- Well, look at what happened
last election, you know?
- Yeah, no, let's talk about that.
You didn't pull it.
When you watch CNBC, when
you watch CNN or Fox,
you're making that choice.
You're making a choice--
- That's true.
But there's a lot of
stealth stuff going on.
I mean, there's three billion data points
a lot of these companies that
are selling and purchasing it,
and selling it to digital marketers,
which is fine to sell you shoes,
but it's different when
it's trying to persuade you
to join a rally--
- But it's not trying to persuade you.
Let's explain.
If you're going in a feed
and somebody knows that it has data around
what you've been doing and
it presents something to you.
- You know that, right, but
if your digital feed is,
for example, like what
Cambridge Analytica did,
which is digital targeted
political marketing,
then you target your
personality weaknesses
that makes you do things
based on your fear
and they know exactly
how to manipulate you
based on your personality profiles.
And you think you're
acting out of free will,
that's the part I have a problem with.
In the food industry--
- But real quick on that.
- Yeah.
- One could argue that that's about
every single thing that happens, period.
I mean, then you have a major problem
with the insurance business, right,
completely, the whole thing.
Because that's completely fear--
- Based on fear.
- It's true but--
- You must also hate parenting.
(laughing)
You must be the biggest
descendant of parenting period
because the entire
structure is 90% fear-based.
- Well, I don't think that's a good way
to raise your kids, as terrifying--
- Nor do I.
But I think what's really interesting is,
I think, instead of going into this portal
that we're not in control,
what we need to have a
bigger conversation about
is accountability.
- Yes, we can, for sure.
- If you're selling "Food Fix"--
- [Mark] Yes.
- Then you better really also,
in an equal parallel,
understand that targeting,
like we're talking about
one in the same game, right?
In the fact of like, the
unlock to all this actually
is starting to get into an ecosystem
where we do feel in control.
- Yeah, absolutely.
But some people, it's hard.
I mean, I work in Cleveland
and I talked to this young woman
who lived in East
Cleveland, a very poor area,
there were no grocery
stores anywhere near her.
Her mother saw her aunt and her uncle
get their limbs amputated from diabetes.
She wanted to feed her kids healthy food.
She had to take two buses--
- I respect that.
- An hour each way,
just to buy vegetables.
- I respect that.
- I mean, that's the challenge,
and all they have around
their neighborhood
is processed food and soda,
they're specifically targeted
by the food industry,
it's really insidious how they do it.
- You know what's really
interesting about that?
You know where my head just went on that?
For fruitful conversation.
It's so interesting that we
talk about how businesses
are being incentivized to
follow consumer behavior.
Like, my brain, I'm an entrepreneur.
When I heard that I'm like ooh,
I want to open a fresh market there.
Like, this is a really
interesting conversation
about like, the right balance
of policy versus entrepreneurship,
and it all leads to just education.
It's just macro awareness.
Like, what I'm so passionate about,
of what you're doing both in your podcast
and this, what we're doing right now,
it's just awareness, right?
Like I'm even weird out,
like it's crazy how like,
placebo or like awareness,
I'm like feeling weird to
even drink this coffee drink--
- You can drink your coffee.
- No, no, but actually, I'm
saying it in a good way.
Like, I get the feedback a lot of people,
like I'm listening to over and over,
and I'm actually now not enjoying
negative people around me
and I'm like shit,
that's what I need to do
for myself around my week.
Like if I just kept listening to you,
I would like, that's real life actually.
- Yeah.
Right.
- To me it's like, how do we
get things to actually happen?
Actually happen?
And I actually think that we--
- How do we get people
to change their behavior?
- I think good intent
people, like you and I,
think a lot about making
something good happen, right?
- Yeah.
- It's just like in us,
it's just our DNA, the
luck of the DNA draw.
We want it, it feels good.
The admiration, the legacy,
like it's the behavior
that we run on, right?
- Absolutely.
- I understand that,
I have my own slight version
of it in different a place.
I think we think a lot about
systematic scale, right?
We spend time thinking about systems--
- Yeah.
- And I'm listening to you,
like if she doesn't have
access like, I get it.
Ironically, what I'm proposing for debate
and conversation is, what if,
'cause we've watched that happen
for the last 70, 80 years,
that American conversation
around systematic.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like hmm,
I wonder if we also really
start thinking about
on an individual basis level too.
- We have to, I mean--
- We have to.
- It's individual but it's
also structural, right?
- [Gary] For sure.
- If 60% of the calories in
America are ultra processed food
that kill 11 million people a year,
it's because the government is funding
the growth of those crops, corn, soy,
and wheat that are turned
into processed food--
- But instead of fighting 187 versus one,
if we started disproportionately
over focusing on it.
By the way, if you
fucking think Burger King
gave a fuck about that Whopper,
until the customer started caring--
- That's what I'm saying.
That's why I'm excited because--
- Me too.
- I think the individuals
making changes in their lives--
- Period.
- And having that voice
drives businesses to
change their products,
to change their behavior.
- Businesses are so moldable,
they don't give a shit.
They just want to do
what the customer wants.
- Well, that's right,
and that's why it's so
empowering in this book
because people actually
can do a lot of things
that drive the marketplace,
that drive what food companies are doing,
that drive their own health to be better,
and their own communities,
and their own family to be better.
- What's an underrated terrible
thing all of us are doing?
Like something, kind of, unusual.
Like you're in this world.
Like give me like a, oh,
you think this is decent
but we're getting.
Like what's a thematic that
you're, like for example,
I'm very undereducated in this,
but like all the new
bars that seem healthy--
- Okay, let's talk about burgers.
Let's talk about plant-based meats.
- Good, there we go.
- [Mark] 'Cause that's a big one.
- See, that's a good one.
I'm excited, I knew this
was a good question.
- [Mark] I'm like this
is a great question.
- I'm fired up.
Get 'em, get 'em doctor.
- So we all want to do a good thing.
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah.
- We hear that the cows are the
equivalent of the atom bomb,
destroying the planet
with their methane burps--
- Go, yeah, yeah.
- And the whole factory farming,
which is true and that should be banned.
- [Gary] Yup, get it.
- And the alternative
is plant-based meats,
Impossible Burger, Beyond Meat.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And both are a little bit different,
but we think we're doing a good thing,
but when you, for example,
dissect Impossible Burger,
one, it's GMO soy.
So it's grown in a way that destructs--
- Hold on, I apologize for your rant
and everyone's gonna make
fun of me and be mad at me,
but Des, when you just
shook your head on that,
you know this to be true
or you just think what
he's saying is interesting?
- [Des] I know Impossible Burger
isn't the same as Beyond Meat.
- Yeah, Beyond Meat, right.
- [Des] As far as like, the ingredients.
- Yeah, they're both
highly processed foods.
- So you're down on those two things.
- Well, let me explain why.
- No, no, by the way, I
know you're going to it,
I'm gonna allow you to, even
though I like to interrupt.
You are--
- I haven't noticed that.
(laughing)
- You're down, you're
down on those two things?
- I am down on industrial processed food--
- Which those two are.
- And those two are.
- Yeah, I'm not looking
to make headlines here.
- Beyond Meat is a little bit better
because it's pea protein,
and it's a little bit
different than the GMO soy.
But the GMO soy is grown in a way
that's destructive to the environment,
that destroys the soil,
that puts glyphosate,
which is extremely toxic, causes cancer,
and destroys your
microbiome, into the food.
And it has 47 novel proteins
that have never been tested in humans,
it's got a strange form of yeast--
- I know nothing but I hear
47 never tested on humans,
I'm already like that's a problem.
- And I'm like, then they're
promoting it as a health food.
If you want to not eat meat,
and you want to try it once in a while,
fine, it's not gonna kill you,
but if you make it a staple,
there's 110 times the amount of glyphosate
in an Impossible Burger
than would be required
to destroy the microbiome of animals.
And glyphosate is around them--
- Back to a common man.
Go ahead, I want you to finish this up.
- So it's RoundUp, which
is basically a weed killer,
that you got in your burger,
and that has real harmful
effects and it does reduce
the amount of climate change contribution,
compared to a factory farm burger,
but if you look at regenerative burgers,
which is cows that are grass finished
and grown in certain ways
that restore the land,
restore everything.
A regeneratively raised burger based on
a lifecycle analysis of both of those,
would reduce carbon by 3 1/2
kilos of carbon per burger
versus the Impossible
Burger adds 3 1/2 kilos.
So you have to eat one meat burger
to offset the plant-based burger
in terms of carbon emissions.
- What is it?
- Regenerative-based burger.
- Regenerative?
- Yeah, which is basically
grass fed but grown in a
way that actually restores
the soil, restores the--
- You earlier mentioned
that the cost of that product is not--
- No, you can get it much cheaper.
Yes, now it's not as
prevalent, it can be scaled.
In fact, the UN said,
that if we do this type of agriculture,
and we take two million
of the five million
degraded hectares of land around the world
and turn it into regenerative agriculture,
which will cost 300 billion dollars,
which is less than we spend
in Medicare on diabetes,
every year, and basically,
the military spends on the
entire world for 60 days,
that we could stop climate
change for 20 years.
Just simply by doing
that form of agriculture.
So if we buy those things,
we're gonna be pushing.
And that's why Nestle's and--
- Who's stopping the growth
of regenerative, like who's--
- Nobody, it's growing like crazy.
- [Gary] Got it.
- Like, Nestle, and Danone, General Mills,
they're all pushing this.
- Do you believe this is
just a matter of time?
- Oh, it's just a matter of time.
This is going to happen.
There's so many--
- And so you care on an
individual basis, right,
like you care for the ones like me at 44,
it's like, hey, six year olds
are going to benefit from this
because it's gonna be the thing, wake up,
you can get some real benefits
from it if you get on board.
- I mean we have 60 harvests left of food
according to the UN,
because of the way we're
destroying the soil.
Like we've lost most of our topsoil,
it's a huge contributor to climate change.
It can all be fixed by
choosing to buy foods
and driving the marketplace
with your choices,
towards regenerative agriculture.
- Can I ask you a question?
- Yeah.
- I've been listening to you communicate,
(Mark laughing)
one thing that I find really
fascinating and I like it,
do you feel like and I
think about this a lot,
do you feel like you're excited
because there's a lot of things
that people are thinking about,
and if you can use the
human on the other side
that's listening right now,
if she or he is excited
about climate change,
that you can use that as the gateway
for them to be healthier?
- It could be climate change.
It can be their own health.
It can be caring about social justice.
It can be caring about our economy.
- You don't give a shit, you
just want them to be better.
- I want people to understand
the situation we're in
and take action and realize
how powerful they are
to make a difference,
but also how they need to use their fork
and vote with their fork,
they need to vote with their voice,
they need to vote with their wallet,
and they need to vote with their vote.
And I think people are apathetic
but we have so much power.
Like you said, Burger King
doesn't give a shit.
- They don't.
- About taking the crap
out of their food.
- And by the way,
they shouldn't.
- But they care 'cause the consumer cares.
- They shouldn't.
Like people, like when
I say they shouldn't,
they should, but you're
asking people to do things
that you wouldn't do.
Like people care about their kid
more than somebody else's kid.
It's real life, it's human.
Another point.
When you were talking,
'cause when you don't want to do shit,
you're looking for excuses.
So that's good.
I don't want to eat.
Like actually, I don't mind.
I'm actually, I like good
food, like healthy foods,
so I'm a little bit lucky, I
just need to be disciplined,
I'm just like a picker and
get ridiculous sometimes.
Let me ask you a question.
One of the things that I get fascinated by
is when you were talking, I
was like ooh, there it is.
And what you said was like, look,
if you want it a couple of
times it's not gonna kill you,
which we love to hear, right?
- Yeah. (laughing)
- We're like what are you saying,
the doctor said I could eat this shit.
And what is a lot of times?
Like once a week, once
a month, once a year?
Talk to me about something
we should consistently eat?
The reverse.
What is a great thing that
you can never eat too much of?
Go.
Is there such a thing?
Or does every human have to be broken down
and based on your own DNA?
- I mean, if you ate
20 pounds of broccoli,
you'd probably get sick, and
your colon would stop up.
- 20 pounds in one shot
or 20 pounds over--
- Yeah, one shot.
- Okay.
(laughing)
No, because listen, I could
eat a lot of broccoli.
I'm about broccoli.
- Somebody can have a
Big Gulp in one shot,
right, that's 750 calories.
If you want to eat 750
calories of broccoli,
it's 21 cups of broccoli.
Good luck with that, right?
- I'm gonna do it.
(Mark laughing)
I'm gonna take this clip--
- He's like, nah, a
hot dog eating contest,
this is a broccoli eating.
- I'm gonna make
a viral TikTok.
(laughing)
- A broccoli eating contest.
- I wanna have a broccoli eating contest.
Are fruits, are vegetables
just like unlimited?
- Yeah, it's unlimited.
I say, you get unlimited refills,
you can eat all the vegetables you want
until you can't eat anymore,
and you'll never get into trouble.
- God, I really like that.
I really like vegetables, a lot.
- Yeah.
It's powerful, that's
what I had for a lunch.
- Is fruit a little bit different
because of the amount of sugar?
- Yeah, fruit, you don't want to have
unlimited amounts of fruit,
I mean, unless you're an athlete and--
- What's the best unlimited fruit?
Is there such a thing?
- Berries.
- Berries are good
'cause they're low in sugar,
they're high in phytochemicals,
they're super nutritionally dense.
And I think, you know,
we're in this moment in time
where we have so many crises,
there's so many silos,
and there's so many problems,
and people feel disempowered,
and there's climate change,
and there's chronic disease,
and there's the economic issues,
and the social justice issues,
and all these problems,
the environmental issues,
and all of them are linked by food.
And that's where we have so much leverage
that we can actually use
to change the system,
both on our own lives, in our
families, in our kitchens,
in our communities, but
also acting politically.
Why do you think that gay
marriage is now legal?
Why do you think there's civil
rights and women's rights?
Why did abolition happen?
- [Gary] You're preaching.
- Because people cared about it,
it wasn't something that
started in Congress.
It ended in Congress.
- Never starts in Congress.
- Right.
- They're on defense.
- That's right.
- Self-serving.
- Exactly.
- By the way, as they should.
Humans, humans don't
bother me with their like,
so I understand.
- Humans don't bother you? (laughing)
- No, I love humans.
I mean it, I understand it.
- Yeah.
- Like I think our
biggest weakness, forget,
before you get to food, get
a relationship with judgment,
which will actually lead
you to understand food.
- [Mark] Yes.
- Our relationship with
judgment, like I don't judge.
A lot of politicians aren't
capable of doing anything else.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- They're career politicians
and if they get voted out, they're scared.
- Yeah.
- Like, I understand.
That's logical, no different
than every other person
listening right now.
- Well, we have to make
it in their self interest
by having the voter and their constituents
speak out.
- That's based on us.
That's based on us.
- Yes, 100%.
I mean, there's a great--
- Do you know how many 18
to 24 year olds have never--
- Never voted?
Do you know how many of them
are not gonna vote right now,
that tweet every day, political stuff?
- Yeah.
- Do you know in
November, how devastated--
- It's terrible.
- Anybody that gives a shit
about kids voting are gonna be?
The kids turnout is gonna be non-existent.
- Yeah, we need to change that.
I mean, we have the right to vote,
which is a rare thing in the world.
I mean--
- By the way, that
sentence isn't doing shit.
- [Mark] I know.
- We've been doing that for 40 years.
- [Mark] Oh, I know.
- No, Doctor, I think this
is really the point here,
because I'm like sitting
here and being very selfish.
I'm like, how am I gonna use you talking,
and Sunan in the corner
of my eye right now,
as a catalyst for me to get
disproportionally better?
I've gotten better, I
can get a lot better.
He's talking to me about like
the sheets I fucking sleep in
and fucking airplanes and like,
and I'm like, I believe him.
And by the way, he sits here
and I'm like he's right,
without knowing anything, he walks out,
I'm going to my next meeting,
I'm like he's 100 fucking
percent, I know it!
Because he's looking and I'm not looking.
It's like anything else.
But we have to,
individuals like you and I,
who are lucky enough
to have mass audiences,
have to have more thoughtful
debates about things like,
I promise you one thing,
more than I know that the
sun will come up tomorrow,
telling 18 year olds that they are lucky
for the right to vote, is a 70-year non--
- No, no, I agree.
- So, let's stop.
Let's start punching them in the face.
- But they care about their future,
they care about climate
change, they care about--
- They care about it on Twitter,
but they don't want to go and register.
We need to have this conversation.
Like, do you think I want to die?
I surely don't.
And I'd like to be
dramatically more educated
about what the fuck you're talking about,
because I'm fundamentally
convinced, sitting in this room,
that you can extend my life
by seven and a half years--
- Or more.
- Respect.
So like, we need to get,
when are we eventually going
to actually figure this out
and understand how this really works,
which is you have to do the other,
what we're trying to do for
last 50 years is not working
when we go into guilt.
Hey, kids, feel guilty, there's countries.
I was born in the Soviet Union.
- Eat everything on your plate,
there's starving kids
in China, no I get it.
- I was born in the Soviet Union.
Very easy for me to connect
to my incredible luxury
of being able to vote.
And I have, I have.
But I do many other things
that I should be doing that I don't.
I think the question that we
need to start talking about
both in food, and we've got
a little more macro here,
is what is the new, what's
our off speed pitch?
Because what we've
separated into is two camps,
that no question, if we mix the two,
there's a lot of good in it.
- Yeah.
- And there's a lot of bad in both,
and what's the new age way to like,
like you've been doing this for 35 years.
The consumer is starting
to get you optimistic,
it never was gonna come
from the systematic change.
Good news, 187 to one, is
about to be 213 to one,
and you know it and I know it.
So how are we gonna fucking hack it?
- I actually am working on that.
I have an elite group
of Washington insiders
who helped Bono launch The One campaign,
which got 87 billions in
appropriations for AIDS in Africa,
where most lawmakers didn't
give a crap about that.
And they did it through
being Washington insiders
and knowing in a Machiavellian way
how to manipulate lawmakers. (chuckles)
I hate to say that but
they know what they need,
they know what's in their constituency,
they know what they're going to vote for,
they know what they're not gonna vote for,
they know what their pain points are,
they know what issues
they're excited about,
and so it's literally a
very deliberate strategy
it's a nonprofit, and it's an advocacy.
So, I started a lobby group
because I was sick and tired of like
having only the good
guys be sitting around
talking on the outside
and not on the inside.
In fact, I was with the guy
who was the head of the Obama
administration's food policy,
Sam Kass, and he said, Mark,
what was striking to me,
was everyday people would
come in from the lobby groups
and they would have these briefing books
with 50 different regulations
and legislative acts,
already written and all the justification,
and they would give it to the lawmakers,
and they wouldn't be having
time to figure it all out,
so they would kind of
follow along with it.
And he said, the whole time I was there,
there wasn't one good
guy who came in and said,
you know, we want to improve
the food system and do this,
an advocacy group for the good guy.
So that's what we're doing.
- So you gotta play within the system?
- You have to do both.
You have to drive a grassroots effort,
which we're doing through a
nonprofit, the Food Fix campaign
and we're doing it
through Food Fix Action.
And it's a fool's errand maybe.
- No, no, no, listen.
- Don Quixote shouting at windmills
but I can't not help it
because I see the massive
nature of the problem,
I see my kids future threatened,
I see the threat, it's like
I feel like I'm on the beach
and there's a tsunami coming
and everybody is getting a sun tan
and I'm like hey, wake up everybody,
we gotta get on this.
- Why do you think that
it's so hard for people
to believe those macro doomsday things?
It's like once--
- It's hard, it's hard
because it doesn't feel real,
like you look out--
- Correct.
- It feels good, the weather's nice.
- Actually, you know where I just went?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- If somebody's listening
can do this for me,
can somebody pull up the articles
that clearly must have
been in the newspaper.
I'm trying to think back when this.
I need to understand
the black plague more.
I bring it up a lot.
I'd like to understand
what the articles were.
The only con I can think of,
that I've had conversations
about this, was Hitler, right?
I've talked to people old
enough or who've studied enough
who can really like physically show me
the articles written up like yeah,
it's not that big of a deal.
It's gonna be okay and then it did.
I think what people need is
a black and white example.
- But I hope because during World War II,
this country came together
to fight a common enemy.
It was sort of like the--
- It's what we're great at.
- Yeah, but it did it in a
very interesting way, you know?
All the Americans had to turn
their lights out at dark.
All the Americans had to ration food,
all the Americans had
to have victory gardens.
40% of the food produced in America
was from victory gardens.
The Americans gave so
much in terms of sacrifice
and reduction in their material benefits
and their efforts and their money
to help save the world
and they did it because they saw
this common threat and enemy.
We don't see that today.
- Let's stick here for a second though.
They also saw that their
son was going to France.
- [Mark] Yes.
- We have to figure out
how to make this selfish.
This noble, nobody turned off their light,
they turned off their lights
'cause John went to fucking war.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And they were scared fuckless
that their son was gonna die.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Like, we have to, as a good guys,
we have to figure out how
to make this shit selfish.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Because this selfless act
is gonna play out on Twitter,
and everyone's gonna look at
everybody else and not vote.
- [Mark] Well, you know--
- 90% of my audience is under 30
and 80% of them are not
registered to vote right now.
Straight talk.
- Yeah.
Well, get on it, guys. (chuckles)
- But get on it said, fuck you, doctor.
I don't give a shit,
I've got $13,000 in debt.
- How many guys in this
room are registered to vote?
- Oh, let's go honest here.
There we go.
I appreciate the, yeah.
I love you, I love you
for not raising your hand.
And by the way, no judgment,
this is back to judgment.
I have no judgment.
I have no judge, zero,
I think we have to...
Us saying to them, get on it.
- Gary, this is your job.
You're a digital marketing expert.
(laughing)
- You'll appreciate this.
It's what I'm doing
right now in the micro.
What I'm doing right now is actually
what I'm asking for all
of us to debate more.
Me making this conversation about this
is the punch line, which is like,
I know that guilt doesn't work.
- No, no.
- Fear does.
- Fear works, right.
- Fear works.
And I also know that information,
what I love about you
and have admired from afar and why,
listen, you're at Vayner's speaker,
we looked at a million names.
I like people who populate information.
I like that you're a human media company.
I like that you do a book.
I do books, I'm a digital guy.
I like that you do podcasts.
Where I'm conversating with you
because I respect you, is--
- Even though you tell
me to fuck off? (laughs)
- When I say fuck off,
I'm talking about them on the other side--
- I know, I know.
- 'Cause they do it to me.
- I'm just teasing you.
- No, I know you are,
but Mark listen,
I read a hundred comments
of fuck you, Gary.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Like you talk about people,
like I'd love to cry in my
Bentley, I don't have money.
I'm like 'cause you don't know
what crying in a Bentley looks like.
- [Mark] Right.
- You have to change your perspective.
I spend my time trying to
figure out the off speed pitch.
The people I admire
the most, you included,
that are out there are
throwing fast balls.
And I'm trying to figure out how to--
- Slow a slow ball.
- Add to the repertoire
because what I know is that
we're talking down and
it's not adding in results.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah, for sure.
- And so I'm like, I'm
trying to use this moment
through our two energies to maybe populate
something in my thought, hear you, listen,
for you, like, what's our off speed pitch?
You know, because we need it,
'cause you know what's gonna happen.
- Well, everybody knows
people in their family,
in their life, who are sick.
Who are sick from food and who get it
and who are suffering.
And that's where the
pain is for most people.
Whether it's mental illness.
I mean, two days ago one
of my wife's good friend,
just committed suicide.
- I'm sorry to hear that.
- And you know, we see for example,
in studies that kids who
can switch from junk food
to healthy food who are teenagers,
reduce suicide by a 100% and suicide is
the third leading cause
of death in teenagers.
- [Gary] For kids, yup.
- So like we know there's
so much suffering out there
and if people got the
connection between the food--
- I love you for that.
- And all these issues.
- That's right.
- It's a big deal.
Why are we having so much
conflict in divisiveness?
'Cause it screws up our brains
and our ability to actually
have the adults in the room,
our reptile brain is the reactive,
impulsive, fighting, aggressive brain
that is not getting moderated
by the adult in the room
when there's a diet
that's causing inflammation in the brain.
This is scientific fact.
- I believe you.
- So this on so many levels is important.
- Are you, because of all
this, I'm listening to you,
are you more concerned
about the Impossibles
and the bar candy, the bar--
- No, no, those are--
- Stick with me for a second.
It's not that we're picking on them.
Let me ask it a different way.
The trend of the last decade
where foods are positioned to look healthy
but are just as unhealthy as,
like I would argue listening to you
I'm like oh wow, he must
be more upset at a Kind bar
than a Snickers bar, because the brand
and I'm not, let's not just use those two.
I'm just saying there's
a very clear movement.
I decided to start losing.
My first move was exercise
and at least, understand calories.
It was that basic, six years ago for me
and now I'm evolving.
And what was fun through
that journey is like,
oh these are tricky,
they look super healthy,
but those are the same
numbers I see on the stuff
that's the shittiest of
shit or supposed to be.
- [Mark] Right.
- That to me is actually
a very interesting
current state of the market,
where I think there's a lot
of people listening right now
that feel pretty decent
about their choices.
- Yeah, I mean you go to Whole
Foods you got a lot of junk.
- [Gary] Correct.
- It's got less
preservatives, less toxic--
- It's packaged nicer.
It looks like your fucking book cover
but actually on the data--
- But it can be full of sugar and starch
and things that really
make people not great.
I mean, it's certainly better
than what you're eating
in traditional grocery store
but it's not necessarily a health food.
- Yeah, no, that's where
this is getting interesting.
In the old world, I love history.
Like when you or maybe
you haven't done this,
when your contemporaries or
other people you respect,
what have we learned
about those European years
where we didn't have as
much of this kind of food,
where it was more market and the bizarre?
What's that data show?
- The data is so clear on
people who eat traditional diets
live a lot longer, they feel better,
there's less obesity--
- A traditional diet.
Explain that.
- I mean, they didn't come from a factory,
it came from a farm. (chuckles)
It's pretty simple.
People ate real food, grown in real soil.
I mean if you eat broccoli today,
it's got 50% less nutrients
than it did 50 years ago
in 1970 when I was 10 years old,
because of how we grow the food
and the depletion of the soil.
So we need to--
- Period.
And so, I always say--
- So where can I buy broccoli
that is as good as the
10 year old you got?
- You can go to your local farmer's market
and maybe find someone who's got
an organic regenerative farm
that's actually enriched soil
because the soil is what
makes the food healthy,
it's what makes it taste good.
I mean, I was just having
dinner with a friend
who just got back from Rwanda.
She said the soil was amazing, you know,
80% of the people are farmers,
their subsistence farmers,
the flavors, the juices,
the colors were so amazing
because it was actually food
that was not industrial food,
which is what most of
us eat in the world now.
- For anybody who's
listening and not watching,
just a fun fact, when he asked me,
how old did you think I was,
it was really a smart
reason he asked that.
I went even a little bit high
because I knew what he was trying to do.
If you are somebody,
let me give the three people
that might go with this.
He looks fucking phenomenal.
(laughing) And so maybe
one of the, you know,
a lot of you are vain fuckers
and if you don't like all the other stuff,
like you don't give a
shit about the environment
or life or anything else,
and you just want to look
better for longer, there's that.
- Well, there's that.
- True?
- Yeah, true.
I mean, I wanna live to be 120,
my friend David Asprey
wants to live till 180,
I'm not sure about that yet, we'll see,
but I did my biological--
- You wanna go to 120?
- At least, my biological age,
I'm 60, is 39.
- Is that true?
- Yes, I checked my telomeres,
my biological age is 39.
- Did all this good eating
give you really pretty eyes too
or is that was just luck?
- I think I was born with that. (laughs)
- They're some nice
looking eyes, I like them.
In my Helter Skelter nature
and I use it to try to
find different insights
because, listen, for
everybody who's mad at me
for cutting off the great
Dr. Mark Hyman, good news,
he does 800 fucking other podcasts,
and they all have the same structure
and you can go listen to that.
In my great hope to find different
angles to great insights,
what didn't we touch on
that you'd like to hit on
before we get out of here?
- Oh gosh, I just want
people to understand that,
you know, it's sort of like,
when you mentioned Nazi Germany.
You know, imagine a Holocaust
of people dying every year.
We're just not paying attention.
Everybody's freaked out about coronavirus.
- Right.
Right, I love you for this, keep going.
- I mean, like 11 million people,
I think that's conservative.
And we're asleep.
It's like we're like
the Jews in Nazi Germany
when they marched into Poland,
where my ancestors were shot to death
in their home and in concentration camps,
we're like that and we don't
believe that this is happening
and we're sort of in this
dark space invisibility.
And I just hope that people
wake up to understand
that they have power to change this,
that this is not a joke, this
is not a dress rehearsal,
that our own personal
interests are at stake,
our ability to thrive
and have healthy lives
and our families to be
healthy and not have
them ridden by chronic
disease and the planet.
I hate to say it, but
we live in this thing
and if you look from space,
there's no borders anywhere.
I mean, I literally was
sitting with a guy two days ago
on a couch who was the
minister of tourism for Tahiti.
And he said, they are
aggressively strategizing building
and designing floating cities
because in a few years,
their entire countries
are gonna be underwater.
Like this is real, guys.
- Miami.
- Miami's got octopus in the parking lots.
- Yeah, Miami.
So, you know--
- Which I'm weirdly happy
about 'cause fuck the Dolphins.
(laughing)
And when Miami goes underwater,
that should be two automatic Jet wins,
so if the NFL's listening,
not to shed too much light
on a serious conversation
but that would be good,
I'm happy about that,
I wanna be two and O.
- [Mark] Yeah, that might
have to be the, you know.
- No, but really I mean it's funny, right?
Because again, the reason
I bring that up is,
A, a little bit for the
Jets joke for my fans,
and really when I say my fans I mean me,
I just wanted to make
that joke for myself.
(Mark laughing)
But B, much more importantly,
we're very insular--
- Yeah.
- A whole lot of people
listening don't have passports
or have never been.
Like you don't need
Tahiti, it's called Miami.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You been to Miami?
- And that's where I'm going a little bit
with John going to war.
The thing that is very clear to me,
historically is how do
we make this selfish?
- Yeah, you're right, you're right.
- And what's interesting is your subject
should not be as hard as other things.
- No.
- This one's pretty blatant,
like do you want to live longer?
That seems selfish, but for some reason,
it's not connecting to the
level that I think it should,
as somebody who's actually living that.
So I'm like mm.
- Well I think the understanding,
I mean, in medicine--
- I hate medicine.
- There's very little understanding
that food is the biggest cause
of these chronic diseases
and it's the cure.
And I think most people don't
hear from their doctors,
they don't realize, oh, I have diabetes,
I have heart failure,
I have autoimmune diseases,
I have chronic digestive issues,
I have headaches and migraines
and this, and that, and anything,
and then they think, oh
this is just what I got.
No, it's guaranteed most of it
is caused by our crappy diet.
- So don't eat like,
for all the basic guys and
gals like me to wrap up,
don't eat things from factories.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- That's like a good one.
- If it was made in a plant, don't eat it.
If it was grown in a
plant, you can eat it.
- That's your little,
do you have that hoodie?
Do you have a hoodie that says that?
- No, that's from Michael Pollan.
- That's what you need.
That's good.
That's a good one.
So that's it, huh?
- I have another simple one.
If you believe in God
or nature if you don't believe in God,
ask yourself a question whenever
you're gonna eat something.
Did God make this or did man make this?
Did God make a Twinkie, no,
did he make an avocado, yeah.
- But you just told me
an avocado potentially
is so much shittier, so there's like a--
- Why is is not, oh.
- Well, you told me the
broccoli is fucking way worse
than 19 fucking 59.
- Yes, that's true.
- We need to get back
to a better food system
to grow better food, but it's
still better than a Twinkie.
- Fair enough, but I'm lucky enough
to live in New York City
and back to your story of
two buses, that's hard,
but the far majority of people
listening right now have options.
So for us that do have options,
how do we need to think about the thing?
I'm like, yeah, God made
that banana but that's,
but let me tell you when I actually first
started paying attention.
I'm like out of nowhere
a decade ago I'm like,
I don't remember
blueberries being this big.
- Yeah.
- Like, when Barry Bonds and
McGwire started hitting homers.
I'm like, you know,
these fucking blueberries are big as fuck.
- Yeah, they must be taking steroids.
- 100%, so what about that?
Talk to me about that within the broccoli
and the blueberries that
look like fucking The Hulk.
- Sure, you know most
of our crops are gone.
We had literally hundreds and
hundreds of species of plants,
we had hundreds of varieties of apples.
Now there's basically three
plants that we eat corn,
wheat and soy, that's 60% of our calories.
And there's about 12 plants
that make up the rest of our diet
and most of those are grown in ways
that are for shelf stable or for transport
or for size and not for
flavor and not for nutrition
and not for actually health.
And I think that's why we're seeing this
sort of our depleted diet.
And when you go to a foreign country,
you go to their markets and
you see stuff you never saw,
you see foods that look so strange,
you see incredible flavors.
I mean, even like the fingerling potatoes,
David Bouley was a chef here in New York,
brought them from Peru.
People were like what is this?
But they turned out to be
so much more nutritious,
so much more flavorful.
- You know where this is going, right?
War.
Like I hear you talking
right now and I'm like fuck.
I hope this doesn't
happen during my watch,
but like if this is how it's gonna be
this is gonna be a resource war game
and we're gonna be like, you know,
this is just what happens.
- Yeah.
- No different than gold
and this is just what's gonna happen.
- I mean, honestly.
- No, I mean it.
- You're right, you're right.
I mean, you have no idea how bad it is
because the way we're
growing food is destroying
our ability to grow food, why?
Because it causes climate
change, it degrades the soil,
and so the food insecurity
issues are gonna be huge.
And then the climate refugees,
the Syrian refugee crisis
was a million Syrian refugees.
We're talking according to the UN,
200 million to a billion climate refugees
within a few years.
Like, what are we gonna
do with all those people?
That's gonna create political instability,
that's gonna cause war,
it's gonna cause violence.
I mean, they're coming over here.
I mean, we've got to figure this out.
- Final point, if people are buying
what you're putting down,
is this, I'm a simple man.
Is this like hey, get
a little more educated
on how you can eat from
farms or things, like--
- Yeah, there's really something.
On FoodFixBook.com there's
a downloadable action guide.
All the 20 actions you can
take to make a difference
for yourself and your food system.
And if you want to get
politically involved,
how to do that, what to advocate for.
If you want to go in your schools
and get your schools eating
healthier food, how to do that.
If you want to go to your
local community, city council,
and say we want to accomplish
the ordinance in our town.
There's simple things
you can do as individuals
that make a huge difference
and we are seeing it.
I mean, when I saw the--
- We are seeing it.
- Burger King ad, I was
like, yes, you know.
- What about fasting?
- Fasting, well, that's a
whole nother topic but--
- Give me your 12 seconds of that.
Are you into that?
- Yes, yeah.
- Do you fast?
- I do.
- How often?
- Well, I do it maybe an
actual whole day fast,
maybe once a month,
but I usually do what we
call time restricted eating,
which is within an eight hour window.
So I'll sort of eat
dinner, finish by seven,
you can eat by 11 the next day.
It's not that hard.
- No.
- And what that does is it
activates all the repair
and healing mechanisms in your body
that slow aging, that lose belly fat,
that build muscle, that increase
your cognitive function,
that build bone density,
that reduce inflammation,
that activate your antioxidant systems.
So it's a powerful tool
that is not about changing what you eat,
but changing when you eat.
- So the 11:30 p.m. hardcore big dinner
and the 6:00 a.m. donut.
- Bad news, bad news.
Don't eat three hours before bed,
and make sure, you
know, you give yourself.
I mean, why do they call it breakfast?
Break fast.
But if we all eat all night
long and eat when we wake up,
we're not doing that, our bodies--
- Do you believe breakfast
is the best meal of the day
or do you think that was good propaganda?
- You can do your time
restricted eating anytime--
- Thank you, that's all I needed.
Now my mission's done.
- You can do it from
six in the morning until
two in the afternoon.
- I think that just made my fucking day.
- You can do whenever you want. (chuckles)
- Doctor, thank you so much.
- Thank you.